pour l'essentiel il s'agit d'une
expérience destinée à tester les effets
psychologiques que peuvent induire les
longs voyages dans l'espace chez l'homme
à l'image vous avait décollé
une communication avec l'extérieur pas
de lumière naturelle la solitude
ces parties de la stimulation walter
vous recevez ou est ce qu'on est
vous voyez pas que tout ça c'est bidon
c'est pas ce qui était prévu je suis le
seul mec sens et si quelque chose va
vraiment de travers à l'extérieur
mais ces délires fusion pertes de
mémoire hallucination
était envisageable
le gars est sans fond ce n'est qu'un
cauchemar m
je veux bien qu'on me réveille alors
tout ça n'a aucun sens elle a très bien
plus ressemblants
m
on perd tous